alors le festival de la désinformation
basé sur le corps en à virus ou la copie
ça se poursuit oui donc c'est une vidéo
que certaines personnes nous ont envoyé
où on affirme que les animaux sont tués
en celle on dit la chine tue tous ces
animaux à cause du corona vireuse
est ce qu'on voit dans la vidéo qui je
vous préviens est quand même un peu
chaud quand on voit des ports et des
poussins ainsi que des canards qui sont
jetés dans un ravin pour être tuer les
cochons ont effectivement été tuées
massivement en chine en 2018 pas cause
du corona vireuse mais à cause d'une
autre maladie qui s'appelle le virus de
la peste porcine africaine
donc c'était vraiment pour contenir la
propagation de cette épidémie
c'est les canaux donc dans ce que le ce
s'est effectivement ça semble être plus
récents donc on n'a pas pu vérifier
exactement quand ces vidéos là a été
pris mais l' agence de presse reuter a
enquêté au parler à des éleveurs de
volailles qui ont dit qu'effectivement
ils doivent tuer leurs animaux leurs
volailles parce que avec les
quarantaines les routes qui sont bloqués
ils n'arrivent plus à les nourrir
ils reçoivent plus de nourriture et donc
il se retrouve à devoir tuer leurs
animaux
mais ce n'est pas lié directement sur la
contamination en conséquence bougera
indirecte du corps anna virus bouchra on
va poursuivre avec le corona virus et
oui parce qu'avec la faveur à la faveur
du printemps il y en a peut-être qui
seront tentés de s'ouvrir une petite
bière peut-être une petite corona sur
une terrasse éventuellement vous voyez
où je veux en venir vu beaucoup
d'articles ont été produits par des
médias dans bien des cas sérieux là qui
laissent entendre qu'ils avaient nette
baisse des ventes de corona depuis la
mort ce de l'année janvier et aussi le
début du mois de février parce que
j'avais pris peur soudainement de boire
de la corona corne encore on avait
rejoint vous comprenez bon effectivement
les ventes de corona ont baissé mais
surtout en chine
et pas juste la corona la stella artois
la baudroie the également pourquoi parce
qu'en chine on boit beaucoup beaucoup de
bière surtout dans le contexte du nouvel
an chinois mais tout ça a eu lieu avec
les coronavirus en guise de toile de
fond alors évidemment klich noah en but
un peu moins de bière temps de les
restrictions qui avait les gens qui
allaient moins public y avait moins des
changes entre les êtres humains en chine
plus particulière
donc ça rien à voir avec la similitude
entre les deux noms et quand on regarde
les chiffres aux états unis janvier
février des ventes augmentent alors
passons maintenant de la bière ou café
chaud au petit café élections ça se
refuse pas la nouvelle sur facebook en
ce moment on était rendu à 15 mai le
partage ou moto en tournée mais ça
augmente très rapidement et on semble
montrer que ben ya aucune différence
dans des cafés large extra-large dit
martin donc on se fait avoir
vous avez vraiment besoin des
décrypteurs pour vérifier sa passe est
facile de le faire à la maison on veut
le faire pour vous donc elle excitant à
café large et un extra large ici vide
ces conférences les cultiver de temps en
temps quand vous vous voir assez
rapidement le large et pas plus gros que
l'ex trader j'y reste encore de l'espace
dans l'ex trop large
c'est vraiment un trucage assez facile
on voit pas l'intérieur du gobelet vite
dans la vidéo qui circule dont
probablement qui avait déjà deux litres
dans le fond ça prend pas le clan jma
pour le faire
[Musique]